lay
Lift Me Up
hold me down
Allison holker paying tribute to her
late husband Stephen twitch boss I'm so
grateful that I've had Stephen part of
my life Allison shared this beautiful
video to Instagram on Friday a highlight
reel of their life together as a couple
[Music]
to sleep
in the clip Allison takes fans inside
her longtime romance with twitch from
the moment they got engaged to the
moment they got married in 2013. I have
the sweetest husband in the entire world
she also includes their growing family
the couple shared three kids Wesley
Maddox and ziya just like family man
like honestly they're my favorite
they're my favorite people you know what
I mean
[Music]
take some time and stay with me
Allison captioned the touching video
quote to my husband best friend babe Chi
Chalker Superman and father of my
children I love you forever and always
we will forever remember you as a true
Beacon of light that you were and we
will continue to cast your light and
your love throughout the world he was
pure light if you knew him you knew that
if you didn't know him you saw it
the post captioned the attention of
stars like Ellen DeGeneres who twitch
worked with for eight years on her show
she writes quote his light lives on with
all of you actress Jody Sweetin who
shared a close bond with twitch writes
quote love you all so much not a day has
gone by I'm not thinking of all of you
and sending love I'm still in a lot of
shock
um my daughter is really close with
Wesley his daughter and our kids went to
school together and he and I went to
college together and um
yeah it's a lot so
switch was laid to rest in a private
funeral last Wednesday and et's learned
only close family was in attendance
while a larger celebration of life will
be put together soon another store
shares with ET that Allison's making
their kids while being a priority all of
them are different and all of them have
no problem commanding a room even our
little one-year-old like you know adding
quote Allison is making sure that all
the kids know how much their daddy loves
them that he is still with them and his
spirit is still flourishing that this
has nothing to do with them and that
they can do things to help keep his
Spirit Alive
foreign
[Music]